this was a battle they couldn't afford
to lose and they brought everything out
to try to finish the job Street by
street inch by inch they pushed forward
and force Gaddafi's men into retreat
with Gaddafi troops in martyrs square
their advance stuttered off your guard
for a second and you were a sniper's
target
they couldn't see their enemies so they
had to give the Spikers bait even if it
was themselves like Criss crossing the
road knowing gaddafi's gunmen were at
the end of it they have lit some fire to
come here to smoke screen so the snipers
don't know what to shoot at and now
they're trying to draw finish the job
losses just we're taking a lot longer
with the hours passing frustration
forced the pace and the rebels push
forward from a number of different
directions
once inside the square they had to hold
it and hold it then did the Gaddafi men
were outnumbered and outmaneuvered and
their wounded were abandoned as they
fled this was the first time since March
that the rebels had control of the
square and they could scarcely believe
it the green flags favored by the
Gaddafi regime were torn down they have
waited since March for this moment and
they were savoring every second
the people of zaria say hundreds of them
were rounded up after their rebellion
more than five months ago one doctor who
spoke to us back then was jailed for two
months afterwards but recapturing zup is
the time for celebrations they will be
on their guard for your retaliation now
but the aim is to push on to tripoli
they faced a weakened Gaddafi military
this time in Zawya it may not be the
same on the road into the capital Alex
Crawford Sky News Zawya